on a besoin d'avoir une pluralité
d'opinions qui s'exprime par ce qu'il y
a des hommes et des femmes écologistes
de gauche dans notre département il leur
faut des élus pour porter leur parole
est aiguillonné la majorité être capable
de dénoncer ces contradictions être
capable également de dire quand l'action
du département est insuffisante
que ce soit en matière de solidarité je
vous le disais d'éducation de transition
écologique à prendre à bras le corps
face à l'urgence climatique et sur tous
ces sujets l'action du département est
insuffisante
[Musique]
l'action à mon avis du département doit
se concentrer sur les problèmes concrets
de la vie de tous les jours des
yvelinois
je vais vous en citer plusieurs la
question de la santé par exemple dans
notre département nous devons nous
investir d'autant plus que nous avons
une université je vous le rappelle une
faculté de médecine qui forment des
centaines de professionnels de santé
accompagnons ces étudiants en
particulier ceux qui sont originaires
des yvelines mais pas que pour leur dire
nous sommes capables de vous accompagner
sur plusieurs années et en contrepartie
on vous demande de vous investir sur le
territoire pendant dix ans par exemple
pendant 15 ans et vous savez qu'une fois
qu'un médecin s'installe
s'il est bien là où il s'installe en
général il restera toute sa carrière
une des compétences du département les
français ne le savent pas assez
le département est compétent en matière
de handicap notamment ce sont des
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées qui reconnaissent les droits
des personnes et les accompagnent et
bien notre département est un mauvais
élève
les délais de traitement des demandes
dans notre département sont très longs
ils sont trois fois plus long que les
départements les plus vertueux
nous devons nous réorganiser
administrativement mettre les moyens
humains nécessaires pour accompagner les
demandeurs et monter les dossiers et
veiller à répondre dans des délais très
courts aux demandes légitimes que
peuvent formuler des yvelinois en
situation de handicap